place your right hand on my waist
[Music]
harry potter might be a childhood
highlight but as adults
we can't deny that hogwarts could get
pretty inappropriate like that time when
moaning myrtle was watching harry take a
bath or how about romilda
accidentally forcing ron to fall in love
with her there's plenty more awkwardness
in the wizarding world
so we're hopping on a broom and flying
down memory lane to recap the most
inappropriate moments from all eight
movies and if we're deducting points for
misbehaving well
looks like gryffindor isn't winning the
cup this year
take my hand
movie ginny and harry could never quite
compare to the couple's amazing
chemistry in the books
but they did try to find random moments
to be together and some of them were
weird awkward and downright suggestive
in half-blood prince
ginny runs into harry on the stairs and
bends down to tie his shoe was that
supposed to be romantic it's just as bad
as the moment in deathly hallows part
one where harry zips
ginny's dress for her after staring at
her back for a little
too long and then gets interrupted by
george
morning we get that they wanted to sneak
away for some alone time
but maybe the actors should have cast a
little incendio spell to really get the
sparks flying
that happens to be my sister speaking of
harry and ginny why did ron always have
to get into the middle of things and
make it super awkward
okay maybe harry wasn't respecting the
bro code by dating ron's sister but
what's done is done
in this scene in half blood prince ginny
tries to share a mince pie with harry
after asking him if he trusts her for
some reason was she thinking
of suddenly poisoning him and feeling
guilty but awkward ginny aside
ron comes in and quite obviously sits
between the couple
making the whole situation even more
uncomfortable
come on ron we know what you're trying
to stop them from doing but
let them live a little she looked over
here so you study me would you expect
her to get up and leave
thankfully ron has had his own romantic
relationships to keep him distracted
from messing with harry and ginnies
and of course hermione is our favorite
we don't get to see them for long in
deathly hallows part 2
but we're pretty sure we know what they
got up to when they went to destroy the
horcrux in the chamber of secrets
after succeeding and being soaked in
water the magical couple decides to have
a little makeout break as
a reward for a job well done but by the
time they get back to harry
they're more flustered than they should
be after just a kiss
what else did they get up to down there
just how many secrets is that chamber
hiding
i think i love her the idea of using a
love potion is so messed up it's even
more messed up that the students get to
see it being made in potions class
and much worse that they can simply buy
a bottle in hogsmeade
the girls seem to super into the idea of
casting a love spell on an unsuspecting
wizard but romilda vayne was the one who
actually went for it
she gives hairy chocolates laced with
love potion but ron ends up eating them
instead
and falling immediately and irrationally
in love with her
i'm in love with her all right fine
you're in love with her have you ever
actually met her
love potions are banned at hogwarts but
how are they even still legal
in the wizarding world forcing someone
to fall in love with you and go as crazy
as ron did
should be right up there with the
unforgivable curses
good luck today ron i know you'll be
brilliant ron didn't need felix felicis
to get lucky in the half blood prince
when he wasn't eating bespelled
chocolates he was busy obsessing over
lavender brown
we're just going to go ahead and say
that their entire relationship is
disturbing
even ron admits at one point that they
made out so much his lips were chapped
we didn't really need to know that ron
my lips are getting chapped
we'd also rather forget the couple's
weird pet names for each other
like one one and how they were always
all over each other but thankfully all
it took was ron saying hermione's name
in the infirmary for lavender to run off
and for us to realize he was probably
thinking of snogging her every time he
kissed lavender
well if i were you know who i'd want you
to feel
cut off from everyone else we don't get
to find out a whole lot about luna's
love interest compared to her friends
but we think we found a hint about what
looney lovegood's really into
it's all hidden in the way she treats
harry's broken nose in half blood prince
after draco stomps on harry's face and
leaves him on the train
luna finds him and offers to fix that
pesky nose but not before commenting
that the broken nose
suits him because it makes him look more
devil may care once
she fixes it she just says he looks
exceptionally ordinary
it's a compliment harry welcomes but
we're on to you luna you're totally into
the tough guys
we wish that she would have been around
in goblet of fire because she would
really have hit it off with victor crum
the award for most inappropriate
character might just go to moaning
myrtle who spends her days
lurking in the hogwarts bathrooms but
her most inappropriate moment by far
happens in the goblet of fire when harry
catches moaning myrtle
watching him take a bath with the golden
egg what's even weirder is that she
admits to watching prefects take baths
all the time and when she tries to take
a peek in the water
we're pretty sure it's not the egg that
she's looking at
it's messed up but ghosts gotta do
something for fun right
they won't know which harry potter is
the real one waking up naked in school
is a reoccurring nightmare for most
people
but poor harry kinda had to live through
it in real life when his friends and
teachers paulie juiced
themselves to look like him in deathly
hallows part one
we know how important it was to get
harry to safety but it's awkward just
thinking about him standing around while
his friends
undress themselves while looking just
like him they can basically see
and um feel everything we have a feeling
that everyone might just have avoided
eye contact for a couple of days after
this one
mommy come out we've got loads to tell
you go away
okay so this is awkward but how much of
hermione turned into a cat when she
messed up with that polyjuice potion in
chamber of secrets
we've realized that paulie juice is a
pretty inappropriate invention in the
first place
sure it's unethical to pretend to be
someone else but it's also just
really awkward when hermione turns into
a cat we see that she's covered in fur
and has ears and a tail but who knows
what the rest of her looked like when
she was half feline
and if we were her we probably would not
have looked too closely to find out
i solemnly swear that i am up to no good
the marauders map is a useful tool for a
wizard trying to save the world
or if you're just trying to find out
where your peers are hooking up around
the school
if this thought crossed your mind then
you're not alone because in the credits
for
prisoner of azkaban you can totally see
two students getting busy in the corner
of the map
does that mean that fred and george
could have been using the map to peep in
on people's scandalous school behavior
everyone everyone where they are what
they're doing every minute of every day
brilliant speaking of the marauders map
fred and george
must have noticed that peter pettigrew
aka scabbers the rat
was always in ron's dormitory actually
he was always in ron's bed
it's nice of the twins to let their
brother do whatever he wants but they
should have at least done a little
research when they didn't recognize the
name pettigrew as a fellow gryffindor
their brother could have been sleeping
with the enemy and he was
just not in the way they probably
thought harry
i'm sorry but someone's already asked me
ginny and harry are end game
but harry did have a short fling with
cho chang that wasn't very poor taste
he made out with her in the room of
requirement when she was literally still
crying about losing cedric's cedric
cedric did know this stuff
he was really good honestly maybe you
should have cast lumos because you've
gotta be blind and wandering in the dark
not to notice that cho wasn't over
cedric yet he could have at least waited
until the end of the school year
i'm sure harry's kissing was more than
satisfactory harry's worst kiss wasn't
with joe though
it was definitely with hermione that
whole makeout scene in deathly hallows
might
have been a trick but it was still
really awkward to see these two best
friends wrapped up passionately in each
other's arms
we know the whole image was meant to
upset ron but did they both really have
to be naked
if we were disturbed by the vision just
imagine how ron must have felt well half
brother really
he's completely harmless just like i
said little
holy spirit in his arm hagrid's half
giant which
seems pretty straightforward but when
you think about it a little more
it's kind of hard to explain and we're
happy jk rowling never went into more
detail
hagrid mentions in the movies that he's
only half giant on his mother's side
that means his dad had to get lucky with
a giant
did they use the engorgio spell to make
that possible are there other tricks for
magical inter-species relations
see even the questions are inappropriate
we rest our case
you're a bit more along than i would
have expected particularly room the
middle
we all clapped when hagrid finally gave
dudley what he deserved and cursed him
with a little
pig's tail in the very first harry
potter movie but we can't help but
wonder
what did dudley do with the tale it must
have made for a pretty awkward doctor's
visit
it must have been even more awkward to
live with the tale for a few days
between dudley's tale and aunt marge
being blown up like a balloon
the dursleys family doctor must think
the entire family are medical marvels
nice big smile harry together you and i
rate the front page
gilderoy lockhart is probably one of the
cruelest harry potter characters ever
even though he acts like a stuck-up
prince charming
when he was in the chamber with ron and
harry he just casually came up with the
idea of
messing with their mind so that he could
come out of the whole situation as a
hero
that's completely messed up and one of
the worst things a hogwarts professor
has ever tried to do
we don't really feel bad that he lost
his memory in the process
unless you wish to poison him and i
assure you i would have the greatest
sympathy if you did speaking of terrible
professors
we gotta admit that snape falls into
that category we quote
always all the time after all this time
always and it still brings tears to our
eyes
but snape was definitely not the best
teacher he might have fallen in love
with lily but then
terrorized her son a lot more than was
necessary to keep him safe
plus he spent his whole life obsessed
over a girl who he didn't even really
know that well
snape's devotion to lily might be what
redeemed him in the end
but it also makes it obvious that snape
never really devoted his life to
anything but lily's memory
and that level of obsession is a lot
more inappropriate than it is romantic
serious come on getting your soul sucked
out sounds like a
terrible way to go which is probably why
it's the perfect punishment for a
dementor to dole out but the whole
concept of a fatal kiss
is a really creepy concept imagine the
moment before your soul is taken away
you have to make out with a scary
cloaked creature with a really gross
mouth
you'd think that they'd have a less
intrusive way of punishing their worst
criminal
oh may we suggest some sort of potion
i don't know what that is that's an
invisibility cloak
another inappropriate wizarding
invention is the invisibility cloak
it's a great gift but it also encourages
mischief
who says that moaning myrtle's the only
one peeping on prefects
with an invisibility cloak anyone can
spy on anyone
but who knows how he could use that
cloak when no one's paying attention
turn to page 394.
why hogwarts doesn't have a reproductive
health class
we don't ever see the students taking
math classes or any of that normal stuff
but whether you're a wizard or a muggle
you still have hormones you gotta deal
with
it's obvious that the students at
hogwarts are keeping busy in their spare
time
so they should probably have some sort
of class to teach them about staying
safe
which inappropriate moment was the
funniest are there any others that you
spotted and wanted to share let us know
in the comments section down below
don't forget to like this video if you
had fun and subscribe to the things for
more magical content
thanks for watching we'll see you next
time